primeiramente gostaria de agradecer à
organização do evento ela essa
oportunidade e está duvidando e mostrar
um projeto da revitalização de
guaramiranga onde eu sou o coordenador
deste projecto este projecto já mudou a
vida de muita gente e principalmente
entrar no futuro mais promissor para as
crianças
eu acredito no brasil eu sempre brinco
que o brasil está fadado a dar certo
vamos fazer a nossa parte do resto se
resolve bem porque para miranda é eu
nasci em bola branca eu me criei em
guaramiranga eu estudei em guaramiranga
vez foi do be fazer esse trabalho social
juntamente esse projeto de revitalização
de guará grande eu sou o coordenador que
são para os empresários ajudando e esse
aqui não tem nenhuma conotação política
não me interessa é é seja estou político
bem porque as bananas
nascido em uma família maravilhosa é meu
pai flávio minha mãe margarida
juntamente com sete irmãos moravam para
miranda com muita fartura é meu pai era
da classe média alta é é constituir uma
família maravilhosa minha esposa aqui
prazer de antonieta e meus filhos repete
fabíola mas nem na vida nem tudo são
flores
é a minha família passou pela crise
financeira é tão só nos restou vender
banana
naquela época tinha 19 anos e que tinha
feito na escola preparatória de cadetes
do acabado de retornar
então a gente comprou uma kombi vamos
vender bananas e cansei de chegar
juntamente com meu irmão consegue chegar
a 11 horas da noite estudando então ia
descarregar caminhões de banana isso
mora na aldeota e na época o carro vai
de cada uma série que era o carro de
luxo da época mas graças a deus não ter
detectado que a união faz a força
meu pai fábio a mãe margarida focou os
outros filhos
o mossad engenheiros e um administrador
empresa é resolver então é deixar um
legado para a cidade
então foi imaginei eu juntamente com o
irmão fases caracas resolveu construir
um hotel mas o hotel todo de plástico
reciclado já começaram a me chamar de
doida que aquele não ia dar certo mas
fizemos o hotel algum de vocês aí já
deve ter do hotel é hotel validar dúvida
nem no primeiro há que eu estou de volta
diante da minha primeira participação
aqui tedeschi foi mostrar as casas de
plástico as casas são feitas com
material reciclado você porque o hotel
porque agora miranda é uma cidade a 110
km de fortaleza e irritam a temperatura
que varia de 14 graus 15 graus a 20
graus
então seria é muito focado no turismo
seria uma maneira de alavancar a
partícula e turismo este hotel começou
era de plástico é oficial dizendo que
não é dar certo
hoje já teve é pessoal do japão que vem
só para conhecer o hotel e se você vir
nas redes sociais é hoje o hotel vai dar
duro tem a mão na roda do estado ceará
agora miranga uma das cidades mais
bonitas do brasil também conhecida como
a suíça cearense que vai ficar ainda
mais bonita graças a uma parceria da
prefeitura municipal
o empresário que freqüentam o local e
esse projeto você vai conhecer agora
através da iniciativa dos empresários
joaquim caracas e josevaldo surgiu o
projeto de revitalização de guaramiranga
com a idéia de provocar os empresários
que têm propriedades do município para
ajudarem a transformação da cidade ea
primeira fase do projeto já está sendo
entregue à população a partir de janeiro
de 2013
a cidade começou a mudar os recursos
começarão a ser angariados e o projeto
foi iniciado a cidade que estavam tanto
adormecida começou a ter ares de uma
cidade mais admirada e frequentada
atraindo os seus antigos freqüentadores
e novos admiradores que começaram a
perceber as novas cores e detalhes da
cidade
logo na entrada da cidade todos já
perceberam o início desta tão sonhada
transformação
o monumento de adauto bezerra que estava
desgastado pelo tempo foi restaurado
ganhando novas cores
plantas ganhando uma nova vida à entrada
principal da cidade também ganhou ganhou
palmeiras imperiais perth lares ea
recuperação das calçadas também para dar
as boas vindas aos visitantes
a prefeitura antiga que tinha uma
arquitetura modesta e com cores apagadas
passou a ser um ícone do maciço de
baturité
com arquitetura ao estilo europeu com
novas cores e decorações em sua entrada
e recebendo novo nome em homenagem ao
ex-prefeito draw holanda por seu
inestimável do trabalho em favor do
município
i
a travessa ser o café ganhou novos ares
na e como ganhou a pequena viela antes
esquecida e isso fria pela ação do tempo
foi presenteada com uma reestruturação
completa desde sua pavimentação até as
fachadas que ficaram mais coloridas
passando ainda pelo interior de algumas
casas que também tiveram seus como dos
reformados
essa é forma que foi feito aqui pra loja
o voto págs
é bom estar sempre certo como táxi foi
todo montado no conjunto frei domingos
foram feitas na primeira etapa pequenas
intervenções que melhoraram e muito a
qualidade de vida das pessoas como a
galeria de esgoto que foi tampada
diminuindo o mau cheiro e o volume de
insetos melhor porque aqui era muito
todo mundo diga vive a necessidade era
muito mau cheiro netinha muito assim
como as pessoas gostavam a posse lá aí
corria muito pois aqui agora depois
fizeram também é o que me intenso mau
cheiro
essa revitalização como da primeira
etapa realizada dentro da cidade lá na
rua principal e algumas outras ruas da
cidade aqui no conjunto frei domingos
traz para a população uma satisfação um
sentimento de agradecimento a todos os
empresários e gostaria de kuta com os
outros empresários que ainda não
contribuíram que passa também seu
colaborador deste projeto
a praça central foi limpa e ordenada com
novas plantas quiosques e novos
equipamentos
a praça de alimentação foi organizada e
com mais plantas bancos coletores de
lixo e uma sofisticada cobertura de
madeira com bola e carbonato maior
tecnologia da engenharia civil para dar
mais qualidade durabilidade e chá ao
ponto de maior movimentação da cidade
este projeto de grande importância para
a cidade de guaramiranga não pode parar
ainda existe muito por fazer e essa
parceria público privada tem que
continuar
exemplos de cidadania como este deve ser
seguido por todos novas intervenções já
estão programadas e nós precisamos muito
da sua ajuda para que a segunda etapa
desse projeto seja iniciado mais rápido
seja sejam todos bem vindos à nova
guaramiranga bem pessoal é nós iniciamos
esse projeto em janeiro de 2012 e na
primeira etapa foi da armada na cidade o
hotel para poder alavancar o turismo
então resolvemos entrar no lugarejo
pedro ladeira que era totalmente
esquecida
lá fizemos pavimentações é criamos a
primeira escola profissionalizante é
hoje nós temos um curso de costureira
nós temos um curso de informática e nós
tem um curso de artesões é tão e é essa
aí para si vide exemplo participar de
tipo laboratório para poder replicar nas
outras áreas é outra coisa que fizemos
foi a educação aí eu coloquei ali ita
medicina o que é esse projeto nós
pagamos melhores alunos da cidade é todo
sábado eles têm hora e meia de aula de
português hora e meia de aula de
matemática e tem uma palestra sobre
ética no trabalho sobre empreendedorismo
o aluno que no final do mês tiver a
média é a freqüência leva cem reais e
dessa turma é obrigar toda turma são
obrigados a sair cinco médio esse ano
começou a primeira turma quer merecendo
médio do próximo ano tem dois turma
luan tem três turma porque médio porque
vai ser mais fácil ele voltar e dá a sua
retribuição à cidade e interessante
desde que lançamos o projeto eu falei
pro essa história é essa escola para
escola eu estudei a retranca também na
parte sport dá para tirar o menino das
drogas é de nós em várias intervenções
se encontrar numa escola
a comunidade p g cadeira hora era uma
comunidade esquecida é maltratada
nós não tínhamos água encanada potável
mas multiusuário trazê lo nós não
tínhamos estrada não tinham saneamento e
algumas pessoas faltava à moradia digna
depois que eu tô caracas resolveu dizer
apadrinhar a nossa comunidade e tocará
que é feito um grande trabalho hoje é
nós estamos com traça comprou grau de
com bosque em grande área de lazer uma
piscina de natação
nós também estamos com alguns algumas
estradas que terão feito em algumas
casas que foram construídas
a gente sempre lutou para ter essas
coisas aqui mas através de um jatinho
agora em que conseguiu né
espero muito mais que a comunidade é é
só ganhou e vai ganhar mais uma menina
com essas mudanças aqui e agora quer
chamar sendo criada há 15 dias na
madeira
eu nunca tinha visto uma melhoria como
aproveitar agora eu estou muito
satisfeito muito alegre
eu sei o que eu antes nunca vi aqui
o meu sonho é formado em física ucr
fisco cientista desde pequeno funções
recente sismo vai ter o auxílio de dois
professores língua portuguesa e
matemática e e um site que a gente vai
contar com a ajuda desses acham que
precisará enfrentar o que tiver
dificuldade aqui auxílio dos professores
já que esse site que a gente recebeu um
cartão em uma senha
ele é um cartão válido por um ano você
vai ter acesso urbano mensagem para só
que assim como a gente ganha uma bolsa
a gente vai ter acesso através da escada
pra incentivar cada aluno vai receber
100 áreas sem a divisão e assim eu acho
que não só pelo dinheiro mas um pouco
pra cima a sua bagagem internacional
isso é muito bom não só para quem tem o
dinheiro com que ele fosse atendido pelo
prazer de estudar para se visar um
futuro melhor
o projeto é bom futebol e futsal
guaramiranga que tem cerca de 100 a 150
alunos aqui tanto na sede como na
comunidade que hoje nós temos dois
alunos nós fruto do nosso trabalho em
dois grandes projetos de futsal do
estado que é o bem de tudo que é quem
tem o diego souza e também no projeto
manoel tobias final o atual artilheiro
do campeonato cearense
o márcio allan esse projeto e do reforço
escolar é eu passei e mail é uma empresa
reforço escolar 24 horas onde você tem
entra na internet têm aulas ao vivo os
melhores professores
eu passei o email é pedir no orçamento é
ele mandava de graça
estamos fazendo isso aí é agradeço
responsável com agora sem pagar
exatamente o que estão é outra coisa
também que não estamos fazendo é o
resgate da história de guaramiranga é
deixar registrada a nossa história e nós
conseguimos tocar cedo técnica vai jogar
aqui no estado de 1740 1940 estamos
restaurando todo ele
é o sonhar pequeno ou sonhar grande é o
mesmo preço né então todos nós devemos
sonhar grande
esse projeto é exatamente dois anos né e
vai continuar pelo menos até eu morrer é
e aqui não é como um sonho a eu tô indo
a dez anos depois no ano 2024 né vai a
sair a notícia o jornal folha de são
paulo dizendo que o iêmen mais na prova
com a medicina no brasil é o município
de guaramiranga certo eu não tenho a
menor dúvida para brega município que
mais a própria medicina no brasil usa eu
estou botando a medicina outra coisa se
ele depois ter idéia é esse projeto
essas 26 crianças nós temos dois
professores o coordenador é a média
desse projeto custa 5 mil reais.o meza e
eu já consegui mensagem da começ 100 mil
reais é deixar vamos colocar mais alunos
a bunda e quem é ou seria quem ajuda a
cota vale é varia de 100 a 500 reais
meu muito obrigado